was was was macht die junge
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video heute spielen wir wieder und zwar
mit dem notes schon wieder jemand wenn
ein engländer grund eine runde krankheit
hat fällt der eben ihm warm ist keine
antworten unfall nachdem luca letztens
verloren hat und in der bestrahlt machen
musste vorgestern was ist mit dir los
jetzt immer die gelegenheit sich hier zu
rechnen
ich wollte immer die möglichkeit geben
sich zu revanchieren war jeder hat eine
zweite chance verdient auch blut für die
stürmer jeff goldblum wie mache ich das
öl kommt man da unten
was ist also geht das überhaupt durch
den 1
durchgekommen mit dem aussetzer mit der
die lücken immer ungelegen
ein gutes timing was kann ich was kann
ich nicht mehr weiß der dummkopf
übrigens leute ich habe mir da oben im
eigenen namen erstellt jetzt heißt es
nein das gefällt mir alles nicht wahr
das augenlicht ist hier bitteschön jo
alter was war da boavista die kurve
nehmen gucken was die kurven exploit ich
hab gar nicht verbissen richten
steht ihr so viel rein ballern können
alter schwede tod macht ja ich weiß
deswegen setzt du gott will was sommer
gestorben walker 2 war dass ich gleich
bisher ruhig bin aber es ist schon so
spät im spiel
es ist einfach nach 12 wir leben ja
ich weiß gar nicht wann gehst du endlich
normalerweise ins bett ich gehe so um
zwei bis drei monaten ist ja oft zu
fahren voll schön vom perfekte kreise
älter nein nein ich will nicht langsamer
machen
oh ja ja nein da hin oh mein gott das
war dann gehe ich sonst mal so kennen
ich würde sagen eigentlich sage ich mir
so ab 11 würde ich schon gern im bett
liegend habe ich halt aber irgendwie war
ich halt bei dem live dabei und ich
jetzt doch gerade wegen der aufnahmen ab
11 uhr so 11 uhr junge 11 uhr so möchte
ich gerne im bett liegen schaffe ich
aber nie und dann wird haltbar so ließ
sich letztendlich im bett liege und
handy aus marias 2 uhr helfer
anschließend dann stehst du aufstehst um
8 auf oder alter komm schon du hast du
einen lack mit dem equipment magath
volle breitseite
ich sehe noch klar aber ich bin trotzdem
immer übels müde weil ich möchte einfach
mal ich bin auf der höhe
jawoll endlich mal wieder ein punkt
jetzt kommt die aufholjagd jetzt kommt
na gut der pilz und ein eigener account
wollte ich nur sagen habe ich schon mal
gesagt doppelt erfolgreich
nein auch kaum schreiben ist also
richtig dreist er bewusst in meine
richtung zu drehen
diese aufdränge reimer ich kann sich
verlieren das geht so traurig hatte
angeboten dass wir die wette macht aber
lud zweiter ist nicht nein nein nein
nein nein ich bin bewusst nicht da rein
gegangen weil ich wusste dass sogar ein
willst ja wohl okay ich hatte ein
zeitfenster von einer sekunde bis zu
meinem tod viel langsamer
du musst dich umbringen werde
darum kann ich jetzt durch sogar über ja
was passiert jetzt leben riskieren leben
riskieren das gefällt mir nicht sagt der
junge acht zu sechs politiker wenn ich
das jetzt gewinnen heute ich erwarte
nicht verliert sich gegen dich das
gibt's nicht gerade
vor hewitt kann ich noch mal reden als
ob jetzt nein nein einfach mal kleine
misst gestellt das hat nicht gereicht
jawoll digger wenn ich einen crash in
dem punkt von mir
alter und gummi mauer pass auf ich dich
jetzt noch
es gibt wieder so ein stundenlang tie
break
doch jetzt gewinne ich jetzt bin ich
eine chance oder you know me al awlaki
ja mach ich das leben riskieren leben
riskieren so sieht man tut richtig
bewerben sich aus wie wenn ich dann
nicht gestorben gerade yahoo
das gibt's doch nicht roman endlich die
abbringen lassen was was was was macht
der junge als auch mir das ins bein
pinkelt dass ich so langsam bin
das was von der heutigen folge köpfiger
checkt lukas schlafengehen sky alle
runde machen